[Music]
what's shakin reject nation happy
Christmas Eve it is i admiral humph oh
here that did not work that Star Wars
reference to a not very beloved
character did not work but we're
chugging right along hope you guys are
doing well Gregory is out of town and
you know what they say when Greg's away
the John will continue to make but yeah
there's this Star Wars fan film that's
been floating around the interwebs it is
called Vader Episode one I'm pretty
excited as you know know I am the
resident Star Wars expert here on the
real rejects seen all the movies read
all the books I know all the TV shows
like the back of my hand it's definitely
my favorite thing in this life no but in
all honesty I mean I'm not the world's
greatest Star Wars fan full disclosure
but I do appreciate Star Wars I do like
and enjoy some Star Wars in my life it's
not my favorite thing but especially
this side of it I find very fascinating
I like the idea of fan theories and fan
films I mean not when they get so
rampant that people are like goring each
other over them driving people off of
social media but just the general
speculation you know like the world is
so big that's kind of fascinating so I
am excited to check this video out see
what it's all about
it's also cool to see Star Wars Theory
jump from you know theory based videos
to something more narrative and before
we hop into this video want to give a
quick shout out to everyone who's joined
us on patreon really really appreciates
you guys we got tons of cool stuff over
there including weekly Q&A is I do music
video coverage now and also we have TV
show reactions full-length watch Long's
for shows such as my hero academia
attack on Titan Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood Gotham Riverdale
supernatural it's a really fun time we
got a lot of cool stuff over there a lot
of great people would love it if you
came over there and check this out and
also patron of the day shout out for
Delia Chamberlain at the end of this
video but for right now people let's get
some Star Wars in our in our lives let's
get a force ghost of Christmas yet to
come
going on in our in our in our city I'm
gonna stop rambling down here we lose a
cool logo fit for my understanding this
videos unmonitored as per lucasfilm's
wishes anakin skywalker's dead for eight
months the mysterious Darth Vader has
enforced the Emperor's commands for some
the Empire brings fear for others it
brings hope
but for Vader it brings nothing
[Music]
it
shot smart sort of way
Oh Oh horse choke
[Music]
get used to the dangly feet man whoa
whoa
[Music]
very smartly shot yeah that's cool lose
a little track of how many people are
being oh
yes whoa
is that like a futur en garde such a
cool costume
his pork eye in the middle
it's full reversal dark battle
Oh tearing up the floor of the force the
[Music]
dockside
oh I like all these close-ups on his
specs for a second I thought I thought
it was like a drink but it's a slight
favor hmm anybody you won't watch Star
Wars - yes
I wonder how many people are clamoring
in the comments about their appreciation
of this Anakin over the actual whoa
what a match I mean not like it's
dead-on but I'm now sitting here going
to this eg her face a little bit urge
that just to looked a good match oh I
like to see this side of Darth Vader
[Music]
repealed perv over here
it's good for a second they made me
forget about his villany beta whoa damn
so cool this is really cool oh wow
yeah I get that transition in there old
Star Wars pay tires you know what fine
means don't I you freaked out and
secured neurotic and emotional
you
I don't think I would like hanging that
was
it is that we on the sink to the street
oh no wait too many right who slams a
comprehensive plan start a metal band
ascending
Naboo amethyst blade power no one man
should have all that
I won't fail
[Music]
oh wow of course you deceived
I love this weird like messed up trainer
mentality we got going don't eat my hair
honey your hair naboo neighboring plants
by its it's beautiful too
just wondering like where how they
sourced all this or they really shot all
these things and locations you all have
terrible aim commander do you know how
many of you die in a day commander
Anakin Anakin go do
uh-huh mr. holder
oh good use of a beat good that's good
you leave them wanting more
Danny Ramirez hats off written by Danny
Ramirez Star Wars series interesting
I'm not bad man that was thrilling I
really dug that and actually I mean you
know given the state of Star Wars and
just given my thoughts and Star Wars in
general I was actually especially
enthralled by this and I'm pleasantly
surprised by that I'm gonna stay here in
case there's a post-credits scene I'm
gonna skim good check you know not to
not to slight all the people involved
you know but uh but you know just wanna
make sure damn it's got like real movie
credits and everything Oh
[Music]
music - Oh
pretty sweet I gotta give it to you
that's pretty red alright man I feel bad
if you want to catch the rest of those
credits find the video I just figured
this video is already long enough and
it's hard enough to get people to stick
around to the end so yeah if you want to
see the rest of you know all the people
who put their hard work into this by all
means please go subscribe to Star Wars
Theory go give this video some love but
I thought this was really cool like I
said I am NOT the world's biggest Star
Wars fan but I definitely appreciate
some Star Wars and I feel like the
series is in an interesting place at the
moment in terms of just the official
canonical movies and stuff like that a
lot of conflict and you know there's
some ugliness that arises from fandom
when these things happen sometimes it's
just an aspect but this is one of the
things I love the most about fandom is
when fandom gets creative and just off
the Batman hats off to everybody who
worked on this because this is probably
one of the best-looking best feeling
most kind of well-constructed fan films
that I have seen in quite some time and
from what I understand whoever runs Star
Wars Theory Pony DUP you know like a
hundred and ran to make this I guess
according to the rules set forth by
Lucasfilm or or you know the rules for
fan films in general can't crowdfund and
he can't have monetization on the video
so yeah I mean that that right there is
a huge display of passion for Star Wars
and also for this project and this is
the point where I start to think like
you know if you get the right fan you
know some of the fan input could be
pretty good for the series because I
thought this was a really cool take and
a really cool idea in general doing a
sort of what happens to Vader between
the prequels and the original films you
know and I don't have the greatest
recollection of the prequels but I like
having Vader in this transitional place
you know where he is
and clearly you know a lot further along
his dark side path and
Anakin was but still struggling with the
remnants and the emotions and I like
that idea that from what I know about
the force and you know the light side
versus the dark side the dark side is
supposed to be the more emotionally
driven side and I like that there's a
conflict even centered around that where
you have Darth Sidious kind of
encouraging to give in to his rage and
his hatred and things like that and him
struggling with these echoes from the
past of Padme and his love and things
like that and I thought the opening
action scene was so badass and I said
here wondering cuz this reminded me of
the scene at the end of road 1
which thrown in there but at the same
time I was like I'm not complaining
about that it's a pretty badass scene
and also you know it's related to the
overall situation but I sat here during
this wondering like do they repurpose
shots from the movies and stuff like
that and from all I can gather correct
me if I'm wrong but this is all original
and the thing is I was sitting here
watching this and they don't have star
wars money to make this film and it
shows in certain places but I think they
shot this really smart leave their
choice of angles it's like when you go
back you can kind of tell that they're
probably masking a small set and not a
whole lot of resources but I thought
that the way that they shot it in the
way that they use everything at their
disposal really made this feel like a
palpable Star Wars movie you know and I
thought the fight just in and of itself
was cool especially when he blocks all
the blaster rays and then sends them
right back you know kind of like a
crazier version of what we've seen kylo
Ren do lately and yeah just having this
debate go on between Sidious and Darth
Vader because they're very different
entities even though they are
technically on the same side and it
props to the Sidious guy does that voice
you know no taking this from Darth
Vader's perspective and seeing that
while yeah it's funny you're watching
this and you're like all of our
protagonists are evil but they kind of
trick you into sort of rooting for Darth
Vader and wanting to see him progress on
his journey you know become more fully
realized and also dick take clap back at
City as cos cities is kind of an
you
dick and I thought it was cool to get
that little mislead there with Padme and
and young Anakin a little flashback
Anakin there just a sidebar I like the
kid who played young Anakin for like the
half a second he was in here I mean I
feel bad for the actual actor and I know
that people haven't been too kinda I
know his life hasn't been great since
making these movies but huh
but that stuck out to me and I like
little Padme sequence I thought the
actress that got was like a good blend
of being like a good match for some of
Natalie Portman's facial features while
also not being just like a look-alike or
or looking distractingly like her but
that was good casting there and yeah
that mislead what it turns back into
Sidious you know I guess you could see
that coming but even still I thought
that was a cool little moment there
because it's just nice to get this side
I like seeing Darth Vader with some
conflict and with some struggle because
I'm just used to seeing him being this
all-powerful villain for the most part
it's funny it's like we got three movies
about the rise of Darth Vader yet I have
already found this at least in these few
minutes here more kind of rollicking and
thrilling and engaging and then I love
this transition to where he wakes up and
it's ostensibly a dream and he's in the
suspended animation state you know with
just his torso body I love the look of
this and then he steps in and has the
actual conversation with Sidious
I found this relationship the portrayal
of their relationship very fascinating
cuz it is volatile and you have city as
pushing him and egging him so much you
know kind of urging him he's like hey
man if you want strike me down come on
Vader plays it cool and I don't know I
just yes seeing that that's the main
takeaway I got from this was just seeing
Vader from this perspective sort of at
the rise toward what will eventually
become the Star Wars that we all got
acquainted with I think his clever and
is cool and it's cool to see him yeah in
this transitional space where it's not
about how he turned to the dark side but
now it's about how he is solidifying his
place in the dark side and rising to the
state that we'll find him in when he
becomes you know the Vader from Star
Wars
full-on and hey man I'll go on record
and say that I like the last Jedi since
I've seen it there are certain elements
of it that I don't love as much as
others but I do appreciate the way that
that movie bothered to kind of go
outside of what I know to be the Star
Wars box in a way that force awakens
didn't not to say that I didn't like
force awakens either buddy you know I
just appreciate when people bring new
things to stuff that's so well worn and
that's the thing about you know as much
as we argue back and forth about fandom
and toxic fandom and and how the
landscape has changed this is my
favorite thing about fandom or one of is
the creative side because just watching
this yeah this is very professional or
at least it comes across very
professional but it also comes across
very passionate and very knowing in a
way were during my viewing experience I
was just sort of like yeah this just
feels like another part of the Star Wars
universe and that's really cool to me
when people who are so dedicated to
something who love it you know to the
point that they know it inside and out
can then contribute to it because that's
the the magic of that's the true magic
of our I mean like there are rights and
laws and copyrights and things like that
but like truly you know everyone as the
great Jack White says you know everyone
Creighton is a member of the family and
this is the celebratory side of fandom
that I really appreciate especially when
it gets this creative and when it turns
out this well know the effects were
really good for most part two I mean
especially when you cut out into space
later on and the ships when he's going
to Naboo to find this rogue Jedi and
yeah man just the sets they got just the
look of everything and and that last
moment man I think I was a little
enthralled by all the stuff that was
going on in that last moment but when
the lights up the amethyst blade or
whatever they say the other lightsaber
lights up and then Vader turns on his
lightsaber like that was just such a
cool moment and a great cliffhanger to
make me really want to get into the next
installment of this from what I
understand this is supposed to be like a
five or six part series so at least from
where I'm standing man hats off for this
because it had appropriately Star Wars
II familiar elements especially like
with the title cards in the beginning it
highlighted the designs you know that
we're definitely in tune with the
overall universes I know it anyway
and I like the relationship they had
between Darth Vader and his really
messed up kind of horrible mentor here
yeah I don't know I would love to see
more of this and I gotta say this is the
kind of stuff that it excites me for
Star Wars it's like I like the new
movies I do think that there is a
certain amount of familiarity that is
being pumped into them you know it's
like my favorite stuff about recent Star
Wars is usually when they branch out and
they do something different
this kind of still imbued with the
spirit of Star Wars and that could be
hit or miss process but I like when they
try to tell new stories or stories from
new perspectives within the Star Wars
universe rather than when they go it's
new characters but it's kind of the same
plot you know so I thought this was
terrific and honestly for as much back
and forth as there is about who's
keeping the gate and who's doing what to
Star Wars and and you know you can't
take everybody's input but for the
unique thing that Star Wars is I feel
like to a degree anyway the community is
something to at least keep an eye on and
kind of test the barometer of from time
to time because clearly you know like
this just came out of the Star Wars fan
community and this is of a certain
quality level and of a certain level of
conception and congruity with the rest
of the story that you know I feel like
the people making these movies at least
owe it to themselves to keep an eye on
all this stuff as well not to steal from
it but just to kind of get the like
stuff like this is a different
communication of the fan vibe to me it's
like here's something that we would want
to see so much that we made it you know
but yeah what did you guys think hit me
up in the comments below let me know
your thoughts and before we wrap this
video up
Adelia Chamberlin want to give a shout
out patron of the day how are you doing
my dear I hope that you're feeling well
towards the holidays right now I want to
shout you out on this video especially
because I know how much you love Star
Wars
I mean I don't that Star Wars is enough
to get you to watch things you never
really would in general and that got me
thinking man I know you're a writer I
know you write a lot and I feel like you
could write a pretty badass
Star Wars fan film so Adelia well I want
for Christmas
besides my two front teeth hahaha
is a Star Wars fan film Chamberlain
style I want to see what she would do
with it which characters you would focus
on a burger you would take the story
would you start with a totally new slate
would you go something like this where
we're in between the events of the
stories that we're familiar with what
would you do in Delia I want to hear
your voice
hit me up with the script we will shoot
it not for as much money as this because
we're not that picking operation yet but
I'm sure we could make something where
you go production values kind of what
they're going for the ideas are good so
I'd like to see what these guys get a
little more money you know that's the
kind of high praise I want to gain from
Star Wars fans and I think you are just
the person to do that so uh
Adelia I hope you're doing well much
love thank you as always just for being
you for chatting with us for keeping us
thoughtful and we will talk to you soon
and as for the rest of you guys hope
y'all are doing well hope you're having
a great holiday season whichever holiday
you celebrate or if you don't I hope
you're just enjoying life in secular
society uh but yeah you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is up
follow us on Stardust app check us out
over there check us out on patreon as
well if you love the channel you want to
help support would very much appreciate
you coming over there got a lot of fun
stuff and that's it for now party people
be well and as always Cheers